I think it's important because it gives
voice to the people it gives a a
quantitative independent assessment of
what part of what the public feels as
opposed to what experts or pundits think
the public feels so often it provides a
quick corrective on what's thought to be
the conventional wisdom about public
opinion there any number of examples
that I could give you about how wrong
the experts are here in Washington in
New York and elsewhere about public
opinion that are revealed or are
revealed by public opinion poll well I
think it's the best way of gauging
public opinion doing something that's
independent that's quantitative that
doesn't give just the loud voices say
and about how things are going or
doesn't give experts so-called experts
the the notion that they know what
public opinion is I think those are
those that that's what makes public
opinion polling pretty important
quantitative qualitative assessments of
public opinion going out and talking to
people and understanding the nuance to
what's behind the numbers I think it's
all awfully important as well and the
other thing is another measure of public
needs behavior how many people are doing
this and how many are doing that you can
see those reflections of public opinion
in official statistics and market trends
and all kinds of things
Oh
in lots of ways first of all public
convenient polling is used not the kind
of polling than I do but about kind of
polling that the political consultants
do do is it has been used now for two
decades to help candidates get elected
it helps shape messages it helps my most
importantly it helps monitor the great
expenditures that political candidates
make these days and media you can't go
out and spend millions of dollars with
no sense of whether or not it's working
until you wake up and they wake up on
Election Day to find out so with the
advent of telephone polling which began
extensively and became the norm in the
1970s that enabled political people to
go into business as political pollsters
as opposed to doing what I do and what
Gallup does which is doing independent
public opinion polling for the media and
for in our case for for the public
itself through through the Pew Research
Center but you have the independent
media pollsters you have the you have
the partisan pollsters they do different
things I don't know it's very hard to
increasingly hard a number of media
organizations for example are taking the
least expensive Road route and they will
do some of these surveys that I think
are an is methodologically sound is what
the CBS New York Times poll does or what
Gallup does or what we do one of the
most important things - for people to do
in evaluating an opinion poll is look at
the question was that that was ask look
at the inferences that are being drawn
from the results of the question and say
say to themselves well how would I have
answered that question and what would
that say about my opinion about what to
do next in Iraq
polling is a tool for leadership it's
not it's not the it's not a program for
leadership and you can abuse a tool
you're gonna overuse it and a leader who
looks to the latest poll findings says
well that's what I should do that's not
a very good leader I mean that's someone
who's not taking this poll and saying
well what am I gonna have to do to get
public acceptance of my policies it's
someone who is interested in in in their
own election or re-election and their
own popularity rather than serving
genuinely serving the public interest
now because so often you see polls
rupaul trend lines reverse themselves
there's a lot of popularity for a
particular figure and all of a sudden
goes into different direction look how
popular President Bush was for a number
of years at polls were fulfilling
self-fulfilling prophecies his approval
ratings would have never come down I
think that the myth the networks have
done a pretty good job of policing
except to insiders what those early
takes on the exit polls have have shown
you know every everyone every every
member of the media community media
political community in Washington by
four o'clock has known what the early
exit polls have been showing the
presidential elections and that has a
different set of problems but in terms
of of the voters themselves
the networks and the media generally
have cleaned up their act and they're
not reporting at 6 o'clock or 7 o'clock
what the polls are suggesting and I
don't think there's much risk that
voting is being discouraged by these
polls
you know come election day you know the
day before the election we put out a
poll and we say this is what we think is
going to happen or this is where the
electorate is as of today and we also
talked about what might happen between
today and tomorrow and the world gets to
since we are on the public record the
world gets to see whether we're right or
wrong now having that challenge and
having that being put up to that kind of
scrutiny you really work very hard to
get it right one of the great things
about my career as I worked with the
pioneers I work for the Georgia Catholic
I could always remember Gallup being
completely flummoxed by people who would
accuse them of being you know a
Republican or a Democrat and you know
what Gallup wanted was they could get
the damn poll right and I think that's
what most of us who work in the public
most of us all of us who work in the
public domain I mean the worst thing the
world is you you've had a poll that's
shown consistently this that or the
other thing and it and reality turns out
to be something else well we have a very
good record and the polls that I've done
have been pretty good I've had a couple
of bull's-eyes on presidential elections
where the numbers were absolutely right
and in every presidential election I
that I've directed though I've been
within the margin of error so to speak
and sometimes even well within the
margin of error right on the nose but
the one that I'll always remember is I
got the New Hampshire primary wrong in
1988 and there's nothing worse than
being publicly wrong it it is a it's
it's a it is a humbling experience
because everyone say hey I thought you
said that so and so is gonna win the New
Hampshire primary and so that you know I
I sincerely hope that somewhere along
the line it doesn't say in my obituary
did this this and this but he got 98
I'm just easy there I'm sure if I'm
hoping it won't at least
well it's easy for us as we go out and
keep polling and we then show that that
we've learned the lesson I mean a Gallup
who again I I started with back in the
late 60s you know he was wrong in 48 -
its shaped views about public opinion
polling certainly shaped his notion
shaped his business and a lot you know
that was an extraordinary event in his
life and in his career and in the course
of polling god they were congressional
hearings about how could the polska how
could all the polls get it wrong and
what he did is he turned his methodology
over to a great statistician at Gallup
and they they revamped what they were
doing I mean you learned from these
experiences but you know to get back to
this point I think having to get it
right not only with regard to the
presidential election but to have your
polls conformed to to what the census is
showing about the distribution of the
population or what official statistics
are showing about you know certain
patterns of behavior or ownership of
things you have to work hard to make the
measures and the questions and the
sampling be accurate